future Hall of Famers Davis is shooting  six Adam switches the holiday and then  the pads inside Stephen actually I'm  gonna start here tonight James Houston  area setting up started the season with  the Phoenix Suns staged down Ben Davis  is able to sneak over the top don't fine  stay seven rebounds  after his 2020 night last night at  Denver Anthony Davis the big thing come  out of his hand that's the thing energy  Ricky  once again Rondo you can tell this off  the free-throw line but you got a  defendant Davis his first three-point  shiny red NBA career is have all today's  a real fragile three-point threat he  regards Davis since it races like that  inside drop it and kick it  he turned down a wide-open layup at the  rim  Davis puts on the brakes and gets the  shooters roll got one so Westbrook got  down that three Davis left alone at ease  [Applause]  good night